no chance for Brandon Lewis is with us
this morning good morning Mr Lewis thank
you for joining us on the program the
U-turn yesterday High rate of tax
um on the face of it it does appear that
it was there to appease back benches
like Michael Gove you wouldn't have got
it through the commons if there'd been a
vote on it
um what's the point in having
convictions if you cave on them at the
earliest opportunity
well we also regularly have a situation
where people criticize politicians for
not listening and I think what you've
seen is the prime minister and the
chancellor listening to what they heard
not just from colleagues but more widely
as well recognizing the issue and the
challenges with the 45p decision and
therefore saying look we've got a big
package here a package about growth
package helping the most vulnerable in
society that's what we want to focus on
this has become a distraction we've
heard we've listened we get it and
that's why they've removed it and I
think actually look you know as
politicians listening to people is what
we we're expected to do and I think it's
right that we've done that okay so there
could be more mini budget u-turns then
well I think the rest of the budget and
the whole point is we've got 95 of the
budget is going forward that uh quasi
quality outlined it's about growth it's
about helping the most vulnerable in
societies arguably the biggest package
to support people on energy that we're
seeing pretty much in the western world
and certainly across Europe and we want
to focus on that and I I think it's
right that that's what we do is that
ruling out your terms or not
well look as I say in government you're
always looking at what you can do what
you can do better what you can deliver
better for people in in the future but I
think we've got a package that is a
strong package it's a package that says
the world that the UK is open for
business so I think we will deliver the
rest of that package as it is it says as
I say to the world that we're open for
business that the UK is a place to
invest that it's competitive globally at
a tax level that encourages business who
are domestic businesses to grow and
employ more people and international
businesses to come here and join the UK
economy and grow their business here as
well that's good because it doesn't just
employ more people it means more tax to
improve Public Services further in the
future okay so you say getting through
the rest of the 95 of the package as it
is in an interview this morning six
times the Prime Minister apparently has
refused to rule out further u-turns was
her determination to get this through
well I think she has got to tell us to
get this through look what we've seen
with the Prime Minister already is
somebody who she outlined in the
leadership campaign the core principles
she stands for that's what we're
delivering it's what we're still focused
on delivering which is a lower tax high
growth economy moving our country
forward to be able to create the jobs
and higher wages for people in the
future and to see growth go back to a
real a growth level that we'll recognize
as growth trying to get to that two and
a half percent we've had a very very
long time of uh stability that's meant
lack of growth and that is not good for
the economy we need to do something
different what the chance of the Prime
Minister set out is a different pathway
I think it's a pathway that will deliver
the growth we want to see that is good
for the whole country it means everybody
in this country is going to have the
ability to earn more money they're going
to have a tax cut for around 30 million
people in the period ahead as a result
of the announcements we made that also
means that there is more money through
the tax that we get when people spend
money when people earn money when
businesses investment businesses grow
all of that goes in to help fund our
brilliant Public Services
yeah you're saying get through this
economic plan as it is the prime
minister is really six times not ruling
out a further U-turn is she talking to
her cabinet
oh well look I talked to the Prime
Minister regularly actually and
obviously we had a cabinet conversation
just a couple of days ago so yeah she
does talk to the cabinet and what's
really good about the Prime Minister I
have to say in my experience in the
early weeks of being in this job is that
she trusts her secretary's estate to get
on and run their departments the chance
to trust us to get on and run our budget
that's how we can get things done that's
how the Department of Justice we've
already been able to expand our tagging
program has been announced just a few
days ago we're looking at what more we
can do to support vulnerable people
particularly women who are involved in
rape and sexual offenses cases going
through the courts again that Court
backlogged down and trying to make sure
we've got a package there that can end
the strike that we're seeing with
criminal barristers to get Justice to
people more quickly I can do that
because the prime ministers put the
trust in me as a secretary of state to
deliver it yeah but you didn't know as
as did all the rest of the cabinet about
the slashing of 45p down to 40p until it
was actually announced the Prime
Minister told us that herself
um last week when did you know about the
U-turn in this top rate of tax
well look two things okay first of all
decisions that are made and
announcements that are made as part of
budget are often and generally are I
have to say my experience been in
cabinet for a few years now
um are kept to the chancellor because
they're not only Market sensitive but
they should be announced to to
Parliament first so there's Market
sensitivity around some of these things
so actually I think that's quite a
normal and common process I got a phone
call very early on uh Monday morning
about the change to to to remove the 45
as I say I think where something like
that's become a distraction for me
phenomenally positive and a big package
to help people across the country I
think I can absolutely see why the
chance of the PM have done it and I
support them in looking at what we are
doing to deliver for people across the
country okay it's not just grant shops
it's not just Michael Gove that are
scratching their claws Nadine Doris who
used to be the culture secretary she's
also been tweeting saying widespread
dismay at the fact that three years of
work has effectively been put on hold no
one asked for this
um she wants she thinks that there
should be a new mandate for this
government which would in other words
mean an election do you think that's a
good idea
look no I think the public have had
we've had a lot of generations a very
short period of time and I think we've
got a couple of years to the Next
Generation I think the public wants to
see us particularly at a difficult time
we're going to let's be frank we are
going to go into a very difficult winter
for people that's why we've put this
substantial package to protect people
from even further challenges with Energy
prices particularly in place I think
people want this get on and deliver on
that job that's how we ensure that at
the next general election we can win I
think we can win I have to say and I
remember Generations in the past people
tell us we're going to win with massive
majorities in 2017 and that didn't
happen I remember being told in 2015 we
were going to lose obviously we won that
election so the polls are a snapshot in
time we as colleagues have to be focused
on what we're doing to deliver for
people and I have to say I'm at
conference I was back in London
yesterday morning for the opening of the
legal year but on Saturday Sunday and
yesterday evening when I was here with
the members I've seen a really positive
um sort of atmosphere around Conference
of people wanting to get on with this
and deliver for people okay the Prime
Minister writing in the telegraph this
morning saying I want to bring the
public with me I want to win hearts and
Minds because I really believe my plan
is the right one for the country less
than two weeks ago she was telling our
Beth Rigby that she was happy to be
unpopular does she no longer believe in
herself
oh she does and I think the two things
actually are a complimentary point
they're not mutually exclusive uh look
what the prime minister's outline is
there are difficult decisions the things
we have to do to move the economy to
change the way we're doing this it will
change can can have disruption and this
is a big change in how we deal with
economic policy in this country in the
sense that although we will obviously
ensure that we remain fiscally
responsible and the chances outline that
and he's got his auction statement on
the 23rd of November which will set out
that medium term plan that people want
to see but also making sure we do move
to a lower tax economy that can drive
growth and what the Prime Minister I
think is rightly saying is that she does
want to show people why that is the
right thing to do but she is prepared to
do the difficult things and in
government that is sometimes the job we
have to do for the right reasons and
does that stretch to capping arise in
benefit payments to average earnings
rather than inflation which would be a
difference between us well I think five
and a half and 10 so half of half as
much
well I think we're getting into
conjecture there is a process around
this the department of work and pensions
Cody Smith the Secretary of State Works
through that over the Autumn she will
make some announcements around that I'm
not going to pre-judge what that will be
but what I would say to people before
people
um get too concerned about this is we've
got a track record as a government for
many years right through kovid and most
recently in this package that the
chancellor announced of doing everything
we can to protect the most vulnerable in
society that has been a driving force
for this government we've done that
consistently I know the prime minister
is focused on ensuring that we are still
doing everything we can to protect the
most vulnerable people but as I say the
benefits structure is one that goes
through a proper process we've got to
let that process happen and the work in
patient secretary will speak to that in
the near future between the Autumn I
mean it wasn't a conjecture because I
wasn't making a statement I was asking a
question do you think that oh no I
appreciate that look yeah absolutely but
but what I mean is people are wondering
about what will happen with the benefits
structure and what the changes will be
if there are any is something that goes
to a proper process the decisions around
that are something the working pensions
team work through and they will make an
announcement through the course of the
Autumn we've got to let them do that
work first what I'm saying for people
though is the underlying principle with
this government has had consistently
through challenges whether it's the
Ukraine war covid has been to protect
the most vulnerable in society that's
why we're seeing those people getting
1200 pound benefit actually through the
announcements that the chancellor made
just a couple of weeks ago sure but
should benefits rise with inflation
yeah no problems I was just asking
whether benefits in your opinion should
rise with inflation
well that's tends to be into pre-judging
the decisions and the discussions
well it has because every the problem is
when we're in the cabinet we all have
Collective responsibilities so it's not
just my opinion when I'm speaking I'm
speaking on behalf of the governor I'm
going to let the working patients
actually do her work I do want to make
sure and I am very supportive of the
work we've always done as a government
as I say which is protecting the most
vulnerable in society okay given that
you're a member of the cabinet and
Collective responsibility you would
expect to be involved in that decision
making
well I'd say all these things tend to
get discussed through cabinet there is a
there's a difference we Market sensitive
things around the budget that's always
been the case through consistent cabinet
but all of these things are things that
go through cabin yes
okay but then um if you do decide that
it needs to be with average earnings
rather than um inflation then you've got
those big beasts that can't be tamed
like Michael Gove and Grant shops again
who've already made their position
um clear
um and the Prime Minister might find
herself in another damaging U-turn how
much do you think that is in the back of
her mind when she's making policy
decisions now
well I've got to say my experience of
working with prime minister is she tends
to focus on what is right for the
country and what he's going to get the
best outcome for people right across our
country look we do work in a
parliamentary democracy that means we
have to work with Parliament we've got
to make sure that what we're doing can
pass in Parliament as well that's just a
reality of a parliamentary democracy I
saw I heard the a click from what Graham
was saying to you earlier and Grant was
making the point even with welfare
benefits it's about making sure that
whatever you do you're clear about what
the argument is that you can show people
why what you're doing is the right thing
as I say with quasi's budget it was one
part of that we we could have rolled the
pitch better we've been open about that
that's why we've moved that away with
the welfare system as I say the team at
the department of work and pensions and
Cody Smith the Secretary of State are
working through that at a moment and
they will be making a statement on that
this awesome but these are not Junior
MPS these are people that were sat
around the cabinet table with you until
a month ago not necessarily with Michael
goes but certainly as far as Grant chaps
is concerned you have to take their
views and opinions into account surely
well one of the things I'm sure that the
team will be doing is looking at a
couple of things one is obviously people
are always going to be listening to
what's out there we've shown actually in
the last few days have probably shown
that she is listening to people that's
why she's made that change with the 45p
rate so yes we do listen to people but
the team at the department of work and
pensions have also got to work through
the numbers to make sure that whatever
they are proposing their source and
works for people can deliver what people
need and as I say it sticks by that core
principle of doing what we can support
the most vulnerable in society
there are suggestions that there is some
fat to be cut out of departments in
order to try to save
um some monies
um what that mean for your department
given that there's a massive backlog in
the court system
oh well I think it's something I know
low so it's a few years ago now when I
was running businesses as well but one
of the things you always do in business
and one because I think is right and
good that we're doing government is
always looking what can you do more
efficiently where can you save money
both in terms of that means there's more
money saved the executor it's good for
the general public or more money you can
spend on other Frontline services so
looking at how you do things more
efficiently is good practice every
business person in the country tends to
do that and certainly it's a good thing
for us to do in government I'm certainly
going to be doing that in my department
for example looking at the court
processor system yes we've got a an
unacceptable backlog that's why I want
to see an end to the criminal Barrister
strike we put forward a really strong
positive package which I hope they'll
accept so we can start getting on top of
that backlog but there are other things
we can do as well around how we
modernize how we use technology we're
doing some of that for example in making
sure that for vulnerable women who are
involved in rape and sexual violence
cases do not necessarily need to be in
court they can use technology and record
their evidence separately we're seeing
with prisoners rather than spending
money always moving them between
business and courts we're spending money
to put technology in so that they can
give evidence from a secure room in
prison as well so there's a whole range
of things we can do and I will always be
looking at how we do things more
efficiently and effectively that's part
of my duty to the public and the people
of Great Britain is keeping them safe
and doing it efficiently
let's end where we started just to
clarify you see a U-turn as a position
of strength rather than weakness despite
a quote from a certain lady 40 years ago
that still resonates today
well she's a great lady and she uh I was
very fortunate she was the vice
Chancellor my University and gave me my
degree look the reality is I think
what's good is that the Prime Minister
feels strong enough and confident enough
to to have listened to people to make a
decision to be able to move on and focus
on this huge package of support we're
putting into for people that will give
not just tax cuts to 30 million people
but give that extra protection around
Energy prices and inflation to the most
vulnerable people in our country so
u-turns are not a weakness
look I think sometimes when you when you
deliver when you're develop developing
policy and delivering policy you've got
to listen to people I think uh generally
people criticize politicians for not
listening and you've got a prime
minister who has listened in the
chancellor has listened and they've
acted okay it's great to talk to you as
always thanks so much indeed for joining
us much appreciated thank you